Jordan mardella donc euh la LFI était
pas la Jean-Luc ménanchon n'était pas la
marche il v organiser une autre marche
he contre l'antisémitisme organisation
d'un rassemblement dit oui monsieur me
dit quelque chose derrière les otages
que plus personne ne parle des otages on
sait qu'il y a des négociations
aujourd'hui qui sont en cours et et on a
oublié d'ailleurs hier en disant que la
marche é'tait pas une marche pour
dénoncer l'antisémitisme c'était aussi
une marche pour penser aux otages qui
sont encore aujourd'hui français
européens ou de toute nationalité
détenue dans la bande de Gaza et
évidemment au 40 de nos concitoyens aux
40 français qui ont perdu la vie dans
lespromes du 7 octobre dernier alors
donc il y a une une autre marche enfin
ils ont créé la polémique au veldive la
France insoumise on le rappelle avait
décidé de boycotter la marche contre
l'antisémitisme qui réunissait tous les
parti leur excuse il ne voulaient pas
défiler à côté de vous bon ça j'aurais
été très mal à l'aise moi de de
manifester je leur ai fait hein nous
quand la République nous a nous convoque
on répond à son appel mais j'aurais été
très mal à l'aise de euh manifesté à
côté de Monsieur guireud ou à côté de
Monsieur Mélenchon qui justifie en fait
le pire et qui justifie la barbarie
alors justement de nombreux militants
dont des familles déporté ont dénoncé
une récupération indécente et c'est vrai
que l'accueil pour la France un smise
n'a pas été fou
[Musique]
regardez
voir alors Gill Verdez juste petite
question vous comprenez la décision de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de ne pas aller à la
marche ah oui ah oui tout à fait mais
mais mais je m'exprime en mon nom propre
he moi je vais pas au marche mais je
n'auris pas non non mais jeanluc
Mélenchon oui parce que moi je n'aurais
pas marché au côté de Monsieur Bardella
il faut que vous sortiez du plateau
alors parce que ah oui c'est vrai je
précise qu ou que marcher contre l'antim
non mais faire le théâtre sur le plateau
de télé là il y a aucun problème c'est
une vraie question je réponds ouais je
vais vous le dire honnêtement quand on a
débattu ici même une fois j'avais une
question à vous poser sur une affaire
judiciaire en dehors du plateau vous
avez toujours été extrêmement courtois
vous débattez je n'ai aucun problème
mais je ne marcherai pas avec vous
jamais jamais je marcher ave vous sauf
si je pas en mourir laisse mais je sais
que vous allez pas mourir plus et si
tuas un gros trajet qui veut te déposer
en voiture tu fais quoi j'ai une
question à vous poser si on marchait
contre l'antisémitisme qui est un fléo
un délit absolu et contre l'islamophobie
qui est un fléo absolu est-ce que vous
marcheriez avec moi combien de morts de
l'islamophobie
en pas combien vous êtes pas prof et je
suis pas votre élève
bon combien monsieur ver il y a eu
combien de mort de l'islamophobie depuis
15 ans dans notre pays donc vous
répondez non
non mais je vous pose une question ah
oui mais moi je vous en ai posé une vous
me répondez pas monur non mais parce que
j'ai pas forcément envie de répondre à
posé mais j'aimerais comprendre votre
question combien de morts sous les
balles et les lames du fondamentalisme
islamiste depuis plus de 10 ans depuis
2012 combien de morts de l'islamophobie
dans notre société l'islamophobie ça
sert à mettre des cibles et des fatois
sur la tête de ceux qui dénoncent
aujourd'hui les territoires conquis par
l'islamisme sur la tête de journalistes
qui ont le
courage sur Non ça permet de mettre des
cibles la tête de ceux qui dénoncent
aujourd'hui de ceux qui comme Charlie
Hebdo se sont permis de faire vivre cet
esprit critique et cet esprit de liberté
l'islamophobie les procès en
islamophobie ça sert à mettre des cibles
sur les gens qui refusent de voir
l'islamisme conquérir l'espace public et
conquérir la société française donc mais
je vous je ne vous accuse de rien
monsieur verd je vous pose une question
vous ne me répondez pas combien de morts
de l'islamophobie en France donc vous
pouvez pas mettre sur le même plan
islamophobie et l'antisémitisme qui a
tué des dizaines et des dizaines de nos
compat a commencé par des enfants de
l'école au zaratora en 2012 où Mohamed
Mera avec un scooter est rentré et a
tiré sur des enfants il a attrapé des
enfant pas tête il leur a tiré une balle
dans la tête c'est ça la
réalitéantisémit une marche nationale
contre contre l'islamophobie et
l'antisémitisme répondez-moi et je vous
répondrai si vous me dites demain on
marche contre l'antisémitisme et contre
le mauvais temps ça pas de sens combien
de morts répondez-moi combien il a Mor
tue ça tue la civilisation française
c'estette islamophobique que vous alors
alors tu peux tu peux dire tu peux dire
non contre l'antisémitisme et les
clichés contre les musulmans peut-être
aussi très bience tu en penses très bien
vous voulez que je marche contre les
clichés ouais si on fait ça je marche
avec vous et il m'en
coûte vous m'pparissez un peu
perchéal voulez pas attendez mais c'est
très juste pour comprendre vous voulez
pas marcher avec moi contre
l'antisémitisme parce qu'il faudrait
ajouter contre relantis islamophobie
pourquoi avec moi je suis responsable de
la montée d'une éventuelle islamophobie
fris non je dénonce votre hypocrisie
c'est tout c'est que hy il y vous qui la
voyez là je sais pas si d'autres tu
voulais dire un truc mais c'est vrai que
comme dit qu'il ne manifeste jamais
manifester après
Charlie dis ils en sont mors des fis sur
l'islamopobie pas y aller hier alors que
c'était justement justement pour la
République pour nos valeurs communes et
je comprends pas pourquoi serait allé
dans le cas où il y avait une autre
cause en fait non j'ai j'ai je suggérais
à Monsieur Bardella éventuellement cette
marche générale t seul argumentaire ton
seul argumentaire concernant cette
marche c'est de dire précisément que tu
ne peux pas marcher contre
l'antisémitisme et que tu ne peux le
faire que si on marche contre
l'antisémitisme et l'islamophobie si
c'est la réalité c'est ta réponse et ça
veut tout dire de la société
d'aujourd'hui ça veut tout dire de qui é
et ben oui mais ça veut tout dire de qui
était à cette marche hier c'était une
partie de la France c'était pas toute la
France il y a une vraie fracture VO je
franchement je pense que notre pays
meurt
aujourd'hui de gens qui ont toujours une
bonne excuse pour pas donc de gens comme
ouais un peu un peu je je vous le dis ça
de manière totalement courtoise mais
mais si vous voulez vu ce qu'on a vécu
là depuis 2012 vu ce qui s'est passé en
Israël vu ce que subissent aujourd'hui
les Français de confession juives
d'aller dire je vais pas marcher en fait
contre l'antisémitisme parce qu'il y a
pas antisémitisme mais islamophobie par
vous êes ça m'a paraît un peu léger mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait moi c'est moi
qui est qui c'est moi qui tient qui
compare le Hamas à un mouvement de
résistance je trouve qu'acord qui qui
fait que les Français de confessions
juives aujourd'hui sont contraains de
retirer les nom des boîtes aux lettres
Gill en 2019 Mélenchon il il a fait un
tweet où il dit à la fin quand je
participe à une marche je regarde les
idées pas ceux qui sont dedans qu'est-ce
qui a changé depuis 2019 mais je suis
pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon je trouve ça
dommage que vous souhaitiez diviser les
Français je trouve que par un populisme
un peu simple vous voulez diviser les
Français entre eux et je pense que la
division n n'est pas bonne dans dans le
temps des des tempêtes que vit la France
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé à Lyon
vous avez vu vous avez vu ou pas on va
reevoir ce qui s'est passé à Lyon
regardez vous allez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez Jordan Marella
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on attaqué alors donc c'était une
réunion pour la Palestine qui a été
perturbée par des par un mouvement
d'ultr droite vous condamnez ça ou pas
oui je condamne d'ailleurs tous les les
les mouvements qui utilisent la violence
qui soit d'ultra gauche ou d'ultra
droite et et je pense que la démocratie
c'est précisément le le pouvoir des la
violence des mots c'estàd que là on a le
droit de pas être d'accord on a le droit
je pas vous diretiv mais on a le droit
d'être dur dans les termes parce que
c'est ça la démocratie et en fait en
étant très dur dans des échanges qu'on
peut avoir ensemble ça évite de recourir
à la violence et c'est ça la démocratie
et je pense que ceux qui ne la
comprennent pas qu'il soit d'ultra
droite ou d'ultra gauche doivent
évidemment tomberé sous le coup de sous
le coup de la loi en l'occurrence être
dissou Jean-Marie Le Pen il est été
antisémite ou pas il s'est évidemment
enfermé dans un dans un antisémiti dans
des provocations antisémit antisémites
pardonnez-moi qui ont amené en 2015 il y
a près d'une décennie maintenant à ce
que Marine Le Pen présidente du Front
national engage une rupture politique
avec son propre père mais moi ce que je
trouve dommage c'est qu'on est passé une
semaine ou c'est norm à parler de
Jean-Marie Le Pen oui mais c'est 95 ans
qui en plus ne peut pas se défendre
c'est le jeu le jeu je veux bien que ce
soit le jeu mais mais je pense qu'on a
assez perd du temps comme ça et voyez
par que vous avez répondu donc vous le
dites voilà vous l'avez vous avez
répondu clairement ce soir oui B il a
été condamné par la justice en fait pour
aller au bout de allons au bout on a
utilisé sur une heure d'interview j'ai
une maladresse en répondant un
journaliste et de cette maladresse j'en
ai fait j'en feraai quand vous êtes en
politique en première ligne et ben vous
êtes forcément amenés parfois à avoir
des mots qui sont mal interprétés
maladroit un pointta victoire c'est une
maladresse non Durafour crématoire c'est
une maladresse ce que vous dites est de
la malhonnêteté parce que je n'ai jamais
dit cela vous me dites on a extrait
d'une d'une interview mais vous l'avez
écouté l'interview où je dis que les
propos de sur le point de déta oui bien
sûr je parle de mon interview voilà moi
c'est c'est mais encore une fois si vous
voulez moi je suis né en 95 j'ai rejoint
le Front national en 2012 et je je
Jean-Marie Le Pen je l'ai croisé trois
fois trois fois dans ma vie merci à tous
merci Jordan d'avoir été avec
nous merci à
vous